[Music]
so the brain is the most complicated
computational device in the known
universe the brain is indeed the most
complex device in the known universe but
it's far from perfect and the human
brain despite all its amazing features
and abilities has many glitches and
problems and brain bugs one ability that
the brain has is to store memories and
we store memories of many different
shapes and forms but the human brain is
also very valuable when it comes to
memory and there's some things that the
brain is very ill suited to remember and
those things are like long lists of
numbers or long lists of unrelated words
or names for that matter and one of the
reasons why is it goes a bit beyond this
of this notion that we didn't evolve to
remember numbers or we didn't evolve to
remember names which is certainly true
but it's a bit deeper than that in terms
of the architecture of the brain so one
of the operational principles to the
extent that we understand how the brain
works we can refer to one of its
principles one of its sort of design
principles if you will is that is what
I'll call an associative architecture
much of what we understand about the
brain is based on associations if
somebody says what's a zebra you know
what a zebra is in part because what
that concept is associated with you
might associate it with Africa with
black and white stripes with it looks
like a horse so we understand to a
certain degree the world around us based
on the associations now when we're
memorizing long lists of numbers or
random names they don't come with any
built-in associations so this results in
something that sometimes we call the
Baker Baker paradox and the Baker Baker
paradox is that it's easier to remember
somebody's profession if they tell you I
am a baker than it is to remember their
name if they tell you my name is mr.
Baker so when you're it's the same word
but
brain is better able to store that
information in the context of a
profession so why is that because when
somebody says I am a baker implicitly
and unconsciously the brain has a number
of associations that already built in
with that concept so maybe you think of
getting up early maybe you think of
funny hats maybe you think of bread now
when somebody says I am the mr. break
Baker that name by itself doesn't have
any implicit connections so it's sort of
standing alone so you don't tap in to
the associative architecture of the
brain of your neural circuits which I
have all these links and connections
between concepts and words and images
and knowledge so the brain as a
computational device is well suited for
certain types of information storage and
processing and ill-suited for others and
understanding what our natural strengths
and weaknesses are certainly makes us
capable of making better decisions many
of the decisions we make end up being
good decisions but many of the decisions
we make are poor decisions and sometimes
we make decisions that are not in our
own best interests in order to
understand how the brain makes decisions
which of course is a mystery we don't
fully understand how the brain works or
where our decisions come from but as a
simplifying rule we do have we often we
often simplify into having two systems
within our brain sometimes we call those
the automatic system and the reflective
system automatic system is sort of quick
and sometimes you can think of that as
your intuition you it's associative in
nature it's emotional it makes quick
sort of heuristic decisions where the
reflective system is much more delivered
at deliberative knowledgebase relies on
symbolic reasoning now to get an idea of
these two systems in operation is a very
loose analogy I can ask you what do cows
drink so the part of your brain that
just thought of milk is your automatic
system so that's the system that didn't
reflect on the answer just popped into
your head milk now hopefully your
reflective system said
whoa wait a minute that's not the
correct answer cows drink water so your
reflective system is a bit slower and
it's a bit fact-based it can analyze
what's just happening so in some
situations we in very complex situations
and pretty sure you don't have all the
facts and we have to make a quick
decision yes the the automatic system
can help us survive if you if you
recognize a dangerous system a dangerous
situation in the middle of a in the
middle of a jungle and you have to act
quickly maybe it's good thing to just
emotionally react to that and in either
fight or flight
now the reflective system in in most
situations comes with education and
learning and we have to struggle a bit
more to tap into the full potential of
our reflective system and I think as
individuals and a society we much of the
learning and education we go through
learns to requires tapping into our
reflective system another example is if
I say if in in certain math problems or
with probability problems those are
things that the brains intuitive system
or automatic system don't work very well
so if I say well I'm going to throw up
four coins
what's the probability that I'll get two
heads and two tails so there are a lot
of people you your brain wants to say
1/2 the probability is 50% that you're
going to get two tails and two heads but
that's if there's anything we know from
probability is that you shouldn't trust
your automatic system because the brain
didn't evolve to do probabilities
quickly or to estimate complex
mathematical questions automatically so
you need the reflective system to come
in and figure out the answer to that
question and that it's 6/16 if you go
through the number of possible
combinations there so you have this
balance between your automatic system
and your reflective system that's
driving most of our decisions and part
of our own self knowledge requires that
we
come to understand when we should rely
on one and when we should rely on the
other
[Music]